hey Shiki did you read any books this
year well of course let me tell you
about them firstly I read what
scientists are up to by Magnus Pike or
more correctly what scientists were up
to in
1966 it was a fun little book where I
learned why distilled alcohol is called
a spirit how banana skins can be used as
an analogy for biological enzymes the
banana skin can cause many people to
fall over and hence is not consumed and
catalyzes the falling of the person to
the ground and I learned of Louis
pasture most famous for milk
sterilization and his Insight of
asymmetry in
biology then I jumped into a big mystery
novel the women and white by wi Collins
I just really enjoyed this book it was a
book that inspired Agatha Christie to
write her Murder Mysteries and a record
to do of the character of Maran halcom
great book keeping with fiction I then R
Tower written by Korean author bamong
hun
this book is a collection of short
stories that all set in you guessed it a
tower I liked it I don't think I
understood it but I will need to reread
it to make the links between the stories
then I read the illusion of knowledge by
Howard catcher I discussed this book
briefly on my channel as I used it to
get a feeling for the research that
catcher was conducting my one sentence
summary was this an interesting
backstory to a recent scientific
preprint on rat Rejuvenation then I read
mushroom by Nick money love it and
massively increased my love for all
things funy on Brey days the win is full
of invisible biology fungal spores as a
source of Airborne particulates the
mushroom is a masterpiece of natural
engineering does any living thing seem
more Supernatural to a child than a
mushroom and almost every cell in a
mushroom is a stem cell so this big
ranges from mushroom biology their role
within the ecosystem and symbiotic
relationships to psychedelics to health
claims a true t a force I also spoke
with Nick about his work after that I
read the living body the first chapter
of the first biological textbook written
by HD Wells that's right the famous
sci-fi author was a scientist in general
it was just shocking to me how much was
known at the time being a modern day
biologist you might assume I know
everything in this book but indeed many
facts were still to be learned and
naturally him being a fiction author
there was also some brilliant pros and
what I've come to realize is that with
less quantitative tools and less
distraction these earlier researchers
were far more detailed in their
observations and also way more patient
to describe them a case in point of his
writing I like this phrase an organ such
as the brain or liver is like the city
during working hours a tissue culture is
like Regent Park on a bank holiday a
spectacle of rather futile Freedom he
also had some hot takes on Aging as a
matter of fact living matter is
potentially Immortal death is a consequ
quence of incomplete organization the
tissues die because they are parts of an
imperfectly balanced body so it seems
from this description that HG Wells was
therefore bullish on the intervening and
aging and perhaps this is reflected in
His science fiction writing however the
only fiction of his that I've actually
read was directly after reading this
which was the time machine short and
thought breaking I liked it after that I
actually went back in time and read how
life began a speculative study in modern
bi ology by David forif I've mentioned
this book on the channel before and I
read it because it listed a number of
questions that he said he would address
and it all seems quite interesting to me
however he makes a number of interesting
points that I actually somewhat
disagreed with mainly because we now
actually have the answer whereas here he
was just being very speculative which to
be fair was given to me in the book
title but nonetheless I like it when
people are speculative it's fun and he
wrote compelling
arguments but besides getting quite spec
ative fory also got a little bit
philosophical and I realized how little
I knew of philosophy so I read
philosophy of biology a very short
introduction by Samir okasher and I've
come to realize that I spend a lot of
time thinking about approximate
questions such as how does this happen
me naturally being a biochemist when I
should also be considering the ultimate
questions which is but why does this
happen why does the cell enter Cellular
in essence anyway after that while I was
reading this I was traveling at the time
and these very short introduction books
as super thin so I also read the immune
system by Paul Clan I've not completed
my note taking from this book but I
think I enjoyed it and like with most
books it has made me want to research a
hundred more
topics from the notes I have made it
seems I got quite excited about how the
body thermostat in the brain is
controlled either way by this part of
the year I knew I was going to be going
to Japan for the summer and whated some
encouragement to keep learning Japanese
so I read the power of language by Fiora
kamaran who was interested in
psycholinguistics a field focused on the
relationship between mind and language I
love the concept that a single word can
convey a complex
concept an extension of this is how our
vocabulary limits how we describe and
see things now as someone who is a
scientist wanting to use sentences to
describe what I observe I therefore
think understanding language is really
important for how we advance in science
and of said it's a cool book anyway
speaking of languages I was able to
deploy some of my Japanese while in
Japan of course uh but before and just
after coming back from the country I
read this short book Convenience St
Woman by seaka Morata a Japanese author
it enters around a 36-year-old called
Kiku who guessed it works in a
convenience store but seems to be
content there and has no desire and no
Ambitions it's funny yet tragic and she
is doing what she wants and defying
Society
expectations however this makes her an
outsider and she misses out on
experiences as people treat her
differently I then read another fiction
book when the wind blows by Raymond
bricks it's a tragic comic book about an
elderly English couple who try and
prepare for an atomic bomb they were
naive and new of for rishma But
ultimately we are all helpless in these
situations I was then full thesa writing
mode so I read have you eaten Grandma by
Charles brand a very funny very British
grammar book end of then because I was
still missing Japan I read a broader in
Japan by chis broad it's funny and
relatable and brought back many memories
of my summer there I learned of the
concept wabby saabi embracing
imperfections which felt very fitting
while writing my thesis then post thesis
submission I read another a very short
introduction book this time on blood by
Chris Cooper I've made a few videos
discussing themes from this book and it
ranges from describing what blood is to
R blood cells and the immune system a
good book after so that I read a feeling
for the organism a biography on the
research of Barbara mlto written by
Evelyn Fox K she was most famous for our
work in M genetics and transposable
elements and I can see many elements of
myself and Barbara in fact we were
actually both born to the same first
name but her parents decided that
Barbara was probably more
suitable anyhow I will leave you with a
phrase from mlin talk which is well you
know when I look at a cell I get down on
that cell and look around and that
really is a secret to her success she
was really focused and paid attention to
detail then I read Tokyo Express by SE
Matsumoto a fiction book which I have
just realized is also a plot which
heavily depends on attention to detail
just this time the timing of
trains I found the book compelling and I
realized as well that this is a book
that would only work in Japan and I will
say no more than NS then most recently I
read the languages of science that came
out in 1963 a collection of essays by
scientists with different background s
though each discussing communication it
ranges from psychology to physics and
Engineering wow Shiki it looks like
you've been busy this year I have I've
read a range of books let me know what
books you've enjoyed this year
below